wir sind eine Partei,
die selbstverständlich für die da sein will,
die von Allen anderen vergessen werden.
das sind Menschen,
denen es nicht so gut geht,
die wenig Einkommen haben.
aber es ist auch die Mittelschicht
und es ist sind auch
viele kleine und mittlere Unternehmen,
die zwar von CDU und FDP
gerne in sonntagsreden adressiert werden,
aber faktisch,
wir erleben das ja
zum Beispiel bei der Frage Bürokratie.
also die FDP setzt n Papier auf und sagt,
sie sind die Helden für Bürokratieabbau.
dabei hat's noch nie so viel zusätzliche Auflagen
gegeben wie jetzt grade in dieser ampelzeit.
also soweit, wir vertreten diese Menschen,
die die richtig kämpfen müssen.
aber auch die Mitte der Gesellschaft
und was die linke vertritt,
müssen sie die linke fragen.
also wir arbeiten uns da nicht dran AB.